we've been talking about this for a
while and effective today it has
happened we've officially expanded the
David Pakman show and what I mean by
that is every day's show is going to be
about 10% longer in duration and the
reason that we've done this is to make
the show better to have more show the
way that we've done it is by eliminating
some advertisements and commercials so
you will notice starting immediately
every day we're going to be producing a
little bit more content so we'll either
have time sometimes it'll be an extra
story on some day sometimes it'll be
slightly longer stories and interviews
on other days and this is actually a
pretty big deal because we already had
four shows that are on broadcast radio
and television in the one hour format
like we are we already had one of the
longest hours of any show right
commercial radio often has 37 to 39
minute hours we had gotten up to more
than a 45-minute hour and even we're
closing in on 50 and now we're actually
close to a 55 minute hour and it's a win
for everybody we get to have more time
to talk about stories with you you get
more show and fewer commercials the bad
side is that in the short term it's
costing us money right because we're
limiting by eliminating ads and adding
show minutes to every hour we're
limiting the number of minutes that we
can have of advertising on the show
which means we're limiting how much
money we can make but it's basically a
bet right I'm not really a betting man
but I'm making the bet that over the
long term we'll have more time for
content which will improve the show grow
the audience and we'll have more people
who might say hey you know what I'll
throw in a dollar or two on patreon or
maybe get myself a membership so that's
effective immediately and along those
lines we are fully relaunching our
patreon page and we're also going to be
doing a membership drive as you know we
are targeting 2,000 patrons we are at
eighteen fifty nine right now
when we hit 2,000 patrons I will do a
very very special live event it will be
a live chess game where I will play
chess against Pat and max on a live
stream when we get to 2,000 patrons
we also are adding a bunch of new perks
patrons now at the $5 level
and all members will get a permanent 15%
discount code for all of our gear this
includes t-shirts and bumper stickers
and coffee patrons at the $10 level get
a free bumper sticker at the $25 level
you'll get a free coffee mug the $50
level gets a free t-shirt and then at
the hundred level and above we've got
some really great packages available
which you can read about at patreon.com
slash david pakman show and you still
have the 40% discount code available for
memberships okay so that is still the
baseline stalwarts number one source of
income for the show david pakman.com
slash membership if you want a 40%
discount code have a 40% discount code
it is vote soon 18 so we're really
exciting new chapter for the show we've
got some great interviews coming up that
max and Pat have been working on we now
are going to have more time to flesh out
ideas with some great guests and I'm
really glad that you are going to be a
part of this so check it out read about
it patreon.com slash david pakman show
david pakman.com slash membership and
send me your thoughts on twitter about
whether you like the expanded david
pakman show I'm on twitter at D Pakman
and the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show